hello unless you know Hindi you wouldn't
understand what I just said what I said
was I wanted to tell you something very
important unless you know my language
you can't understand
it all of you must know and must have
experienced llms in the recent times
large language models are very popularly
known for generating text but it is also
important to know that llms can also do
a very good job of translating languages
why is this important it
seems only about 25% of the internet
users their primary language is
English and more than 65% of the users
on the internet prefer to be provided
information in their primary languages
respective primary languages also more
than 70% of the internet users would
like to receive support issue resolution
Etc in their uh preferred languages now
because they do not receive the help in
their primary languages more than 65% of
these internet users are using machine
translations to get the help that they
need so it seems that machine
translations are Essentials for us to do
business so I'm going to explain machine
translations in two parts first I will
talk about how we have been doing
machine translation so far and then I
will jump to the advantage of the large
language models and how we are going to
do translations from now so let's see
how machine translations are done
machine translations use artificial
intelligence to translate between
languages automatically without any
human help so how do they do that let's
take an example here English Spanish and
Japanese to translate between any of
these languages you need linguistic
rules and you need dictionaries for each
of these
languages and the Machine translations
are done in multiple approaches the rule
based approach the rule-based approach
is the one that predominantly uses the
linguistic rules and the dictionaries
and also the parallel dictionaries that
have the meanings of two different
languages The Source language as well as
the target
language and then we have the second
approach called the statistical approach
it takes a totally different approach of
leveraging the human translations and
learning the patterns from them and
making very smart guesses of those
translations and delivering those
translations both approaches work very
very well by the way we take it one
notch up with the neural approach where
as in rule based and statistical it
actually is looking at each word to get
to the translations nural takes it one
notch of because it is actually looking
at the sentence constructions to do the
translations now as in any other
approach you can take a combination of
these approaches and make it a hybrid
approach so uh as we discussed the
traditional way Li makes use of of the
linguistic rules as well as the
dictionaries right and it goes through
the supervised learning and so on large
language models do the translations
differently right they make use of the
content that is already available in
different languages we call it the large
corpuses of parallel text that is the
examples of the same text in different
languages like English Spanish Japanese
and so on and we feed it to the models
so the large language models as you all
know use the Transformer models and they
have both the encoder and decoder
capabilities on top of that the large
languages models typically make use of
two approaches in doing the
translations number one is the sequence
to sequence approach in the sequence to
sequence approach you can take an uh
input text and feed it to the encoder
right hello how are you
and the encoder goes through the text
and creates the semantic
representation of the text and also
captures the meaning of the text and
passes it on to the decoder now the
decoder is a capturing the semantic
representation in the meaning and
translating it to the
representative target
language you say hello how are you in
English and if your target language is
going to be Spanish you will get
holas the second approach also
interesting is the attention model the
attention model is a little bit of a
lazy model compared to the sequence 2
sequence one attention model is focusing
on the main relevant vocabulary of the
sentence it is not going through the
entire sentence so for example it can
pick up hello and how are you and focus
on the hola and
commas but it is still going to capture
the meaning and the semantic
representation Essence through the
encoder and decoder as you can see uh
the large language models instead of
using the linguistic rules and the
dictionaries are really focusing on
capturing the patterns and the
relationships between the data and
translating it it's quite obvious now
that everybody wants to be communicated
in their own language including our
customers let's go leverage large
language models to meet them at the
table and communicate in their own
language thank you for watching before
you leave please click subscribe and
like